taylor swift just released another song
from her vault
mr perfectly fine and fans think it's
all about
joe jonas
and now joe's wife actress sophie turner
is even weighing
in but first let's break it all down the
song is from 2008 when joe and taylor
dated and it'll be on the upcoming
re-release of fearless
taylor's version
you listen to the lyrics it's clear why
fans think the song is about joe
taylor sings quote but that was when i
got to know mr
change of heart well after taylor and
joe's 2008 breakup he allegedly took to
myspace to address their split
writing quote anytime you are in a
relationship for any length of time
there are going to be issues sometimes
they resolve
other times they lead to a change of
heart
taylor also references an award show
when she ran into her ex
[Music]
not only were both joe and taylor at the
november 2008 american music awards
but joe sat front and center in a
well-pressed suit
and he was mr always wins as the jonas
brothers won the breakthrough
artist award that year i would always
like to keep people
on their toes in that regard i think
that's the best way to be exciting
the song also has lyrical parallels to
another song on the fearless album
forever and always which we pretty much
can assume
was also about joe mr
[Music]
taylor had this to say about joe when
she appeared on the ellen show in 2008
when there was all sorts of speculation
that forever and always
was about him there's one that's about
that guy
that that guy's not in my life anymore
unfortunately
i know and when i look at that person
i'm not even going to be able to
remember the boy who broke up with me
over the phone in 25 seconds when i was
18.
years later she admitted that interview
was one of her biggest regrets
probably when i like put joe jonas on
blast on your show
that was too much yeah
that was too much okay i was 18.
yeah we laugh about it now
oh that's good that was yeah yeah yeah
just all right
teenage stuff there and if you ask joe
there's no more beef between him and
taylor i've moved on
i'm sure taylor's moved on and it feels
nice and we're all friends
it's all good and here's the best part
sophie
joe's now wife posted about the song on
her instagram story
jokingly writing quote it's not not a
bop and
even tagged taylor taylor hilariously
reposted the story herself and responded
quote
forever bending the knee for the queen
of the north plus let's not forget in
2019
joe posted his own rendition of taylor's
song lover
so even if the song is about joe
probably safe to say
it's all water under the bridge plus in
the song invisible string which taylor
dropped on her folklore album last year
fans speculate this lyric hints she may
have sent
joe and sophie a baby gifts who broke my
[Music]
heart
[Music]
you